oh so weird welcome to fat man I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard
hey-oh
all right that's huge for us ladies job
number one tonight represents the 200th
episode of fat man on Batman so it's an
anniversary of sorts number two for
those listening at home likewise it
sounds so weird we are in the courtyard
of the TCL Chinese Theatre what I always
grew up knowing is Grauman's Chinese
Theater if in your head you're listening
at home and you picture like all the
footprints in the cement we are standing
on the foots of giant footsteps of giant
yes I mean it's dry cuz I don't want our
foot pre feet prints sound like we were
getting a score for a second there was a
great show
yes go ahead finish continue I was gonna
say like I've been here I was here when
I was 14 years old and like looking for
r2 and looking for c-3po and suddenly
we're doing a [ __ ] show standing on
these footprints it's nuts there's right
over there 1979 was the first time I
ever came to Los Angeles and I have a
picture still of me and my brother
kneeling in front of the the star wars
of footprints and never once when I was
a kid was like one day I'll come back
and podcast like so it's a big big night
man this is really kind of thrilling
thanks everybody for coming out now to
give you a sense about an idea of why
here and why now because I'm sure some
people at home are like what are they
doing in the courtyard have they lost
their home at the scum and villainy
Cantina are we busking that's kind of
what it sounds like
has Kevin Smith finally thrown in the
towel and now it's playing Silent Bob on
Hollywood Boulevard taking pictures with
people something that Jay has asked me
to do a number
so then Who am I am I like fat Webster
it would be it yes it would be like this
what happened to Emmanuel Lewis for
those listening at home there is lining
up net are the good folks who lined up
it's right in the name they don't bury
the lead it's right there
for the first for the re-releases I
guess back in 99 is that correct you
know what we should do is actually get
somebody who knows history of the
organization who can tell us submit
useful information let's get Sameer from
lining up up here Sameer come on out
[Applause]
jump on in the middle here's a mic for
you Sameer man for the folks at home
tell him your name and what you do Speer
hi my name is Sameer bhakta I'm one of
the organizers for lining up net and
we've been down here doing this since
1999 now what was it what happened in
nine now that was happenstance I was
just a bunch of strangers just going
like we can't wait to see these movies
we're gonna line up again like they did
back in the day was there need to line
up so so way back then you actually had
to stand in line to get your tickets
there was no online ticket sales you
couldn't buy anything on the Internet
the internet was still dial-up and you
know that stupid AOL guy it's so I still
use my own eyes oh that's okay my wife
does too and so you know the only way to
get tickets was that you had to be in
line and so there was a website called
counting down and they organized a bunch
of lines and they said okay well some
people are gonna be in line for a week
some people in two weeks that's it
screwed six freaking weeks on the
streets of Hollywood you know when you
sit on the streets of Hollywood it I
remember the clips back in the day oh
yeah seeing people lined up and I would
be out here from time to time and when
you drove down Hollywood Boulevard you
would see people in like lawn chairs and
stuff like that oh yeah back then you
know we we we didn't have the
relationship we have with the Chinese
and so they the Chinese was like yeah
whatever we don't want anything to do
with you
so we lined up outside of a parking lot
you just I've literally dropped money
and they gave it back to me you
you know what you earned it it's yours
because you literally kept it and you
gave it back you put on it's good that's
very very sweet give me money like it
like a billionaire I draw money dollar
bill
is this a [ __ ] Oprah thing now I
might have to give away money yes now
you go throw bunnies well I'm sorry back
to the story it's cold so yes we were
standing in line outside on the street
in front of a parking lot the parking
lot didn't want anything to do with us
either it was that over what you saw
that I've actually seen yeah yeah Madame
Tussauds there now but it used to just
be an empty parking yeah so parking is
grants parking lot and they hated us and
the Chinese is like and whatever we
don't know anything to do with you where
did everybody pee and shower anywhere
they could okay at the same time yeah
right no you'd sneak into it sneaking of
the restaurants across the street or you
know the Hollywood and Highland wasn't
even built back then right oh my god
yeah it was a different Hollywood so
wait were you allowed to like could you
like hold my lump pulled by the poison
line and go home and shower oh yeah I
mean there was a few people there that
were there all the time but mostly it
was you know you signed in and signed
out and it was a stand of fun you know
but they have a jog-a-thon or a
walkathon this is a standeth on so
everybody would get sponsored by their
family or friends and say I'm gonna go
stand in line for Star Wars for six
weeks and people like you're crazy and I
said I'm gonna do it for this many hours
and night okay great I'll give you two
dollars an hour and you know the more
hours you spent the more money you
earned for the charity and so yeah so it
was at everybody we had this books that
had but he signed in and signed out when
you were there and we tabulated the
hours and the first person with the most
hours in line was the first person
through those doors running in like
crazy asses to go in and grab their
seats it was also it was like a real
democratic system man like meritocracy
laughter you were there the sooner you
got into the theater you know they all
got in the theater for the movie began
right yeah oh yeah what was the point
well like we wanted that best seat you
know right underneath your middle choice
absolute first choice yeah here's my
question about 99 when you guys were all
lined up friendships
oh yeah do people did whether two people
get married no I'm sure nobody had a
child in line but elected people
I believe there might have been one or
two conceived in life could that happen
I 99 we had a rule that if you if you
had sex in line you had to scream out I
love Star Wars at the moment of
completion and it happened on more than
one occasion that's a general rule of my
house man there's there's there's a line
member who shall remain nameless who is
underage at the time and I believe he
lost his innocence in a tent in life it
was 99 folks there it was a different
age
wow man so you go into this thing going
like oh this will be fun and cooky was
it based on hey when I was a kid I saw
people line up in 77 like I always saw
news footage back in Jersey of this
place and people lined up to see the
original release of Star Wars did that
had any play at all yeah I mean you know
people are starting to get back into
Star Wars since the tenzin books started
to come out and then with the special
editions and so you know the the
interest was there and then for those of
us who were there you know back in 99 it
was a different world for fandom I mean
if you think about it there was no
internet there was no internet
communities there was no Facebook none
of that and so you know and being a geek
and being a sci-fi fan was it was a
different world it's not accepted you
were like oh dude you're one of those
people and there's always distinctions
today like you could go to a Comic Con
and you'd have a bunch of people like
looking at Trek he's going look at these
right yes and they were stormtrooper oh
yeah that was like the Trekkies versus
Star Wars people all the time and and so
you know for those of us who were doing
other things you didn't you buried your
fandom you didn't he didn't let you fly
it you didn't walk around in Star Wars
gear it wasn't at every store and so all
of a sudden you got out to this line and
you found you tried mmm these are your
people and it was really an amazing
conglomeration of people from all
different walks all different
ethnicities all different you know
socio-economic statuses and they all
came together because of their love of
this movie you know of course we watched
episode 1 and got horribly disappointed
but you know what and yet we did it
again
mm - and in fact you know the the
original folks that did the line you
know the the fans in line we all got
together from the counting down line and
we created lining up net because you
know the first line was there was some
issues there so we said all right we're
gonna we're gonna make our wars yeah
some of that guy you know that guy's
still around he's here actually just
saying some here you're like that guy is
me no sadly not no but you know it was a
group of friendship and we did it for
the experience cuz we're like okay the
movie sucked but that's six weeks of
people who just got us and you know
around people who you didn't have to
explain it you didn't have to justify it
you didn't have to you know oh I like
Star Wars
oh you're weird it's like no dude I like
Star Wars oh dude let me talk about you
know that scene in Hoth with a womp
button and you didn't have to explain it
you didn't have to go through it you're
like oh my gosh I can sit down and like
wax poetic about you know how much I
hated the Ewoks and people got it and it
was built a career on that ship yeah I
know
trust me I watched it it was it was a
different time now like you know it's
weird when you have to explain to people
like oh there was a time that like you
couldn't really talk about liking things
like Star Wars or comic books you had to
find the right people it was like
tapping under the stall at a bathroom
yeah and just try to find the right
person but now it's like everybody knows
you're there to make sure you don't have
a wide stance okay good point good point
hey do you love Star Wars I love Star
Wars
yeah the code but now everybody knows
this stuff mom your mom knows when last
Jedi was coming out and knows that it's
important like all this is the one that
Ryan Johnson made it my mother literally
told me the directors name and I'm like
I know that you know like how do you
know that she's like I've seen it on the
news yeah she said he's a successful
director tiger
and I told her I said mom I've had Bryan
Johnson on my podcast and she goes
that's my point
[Music]
alright so so at a certain point it
wasn't from 99 forward that it was a
fundraiser and was it always for the
service it was always a fundraiser from
99 it was always for the Starlight
Children's Foundation which is would
explain that's beautiful to explain that
so start the Starlight Children's
Foundation is an international
organization they're around the world
but they do a lot of work in the United
States and their job is to brighten the
lives of sick children worldwide oh my
god that's beautiful which is I mean I
literally saw what they did firsthand
cuz when I was when I was in line in 99
I was a medical student over at
Children's Hospital LA and you know we
had kids that were really sick with
cancer and all kinds of other stuff and
they'd be sitting there and they were
playing these you know it was like
intense Super Nintendo I think and these
star light fun centers and they had play
rooms that were sponsored by starlight
and so you know I got to see that
firsthand even before I joined the line
and then I got here and I said wait
you're raising money for starlet okay
yes I Mia yeah be if I needed another
reason that was a good one and so we've
been really fortunate to partner with
them it's an amazing organization that
do really great work and I strongly
encourage everybody here and in out in
Podcast land to consider donating a few
bucks link if out there it's a WW
starlight org slash lining up perfect
well sold my friend the I believe we're
doing a an auction are we not a lucky
prize draw I think it's the right word
how do they do that
everybody pays ten bucks for a raffle
ticket and the TCL organization is very
generously donated a 55 inch 4k dolby
atmos do all kinds of nasty things to
you when you're not looking
TV for us so if you donate your ten
bucks you get a raffle ticket that's
pretty fantastic do they do it here when
one is they have they done it if they're
doing it right now for all the people
watching right now beautiful alright so
Wow people would get a chance to win a
TV and help out the kid the kids through
starlight that's beautiful now they also
said because I was like we want to talk
to somebody who could tell us
what about what lining-up does and has
done and they said oh you definitely
want to talk to Samir and they said
unless you want to laugh and then you
want to talk to someone else
yeah I'm not I'm not sure it wasn't an
insult like that they said there's a guy
you gotta talk to and we said who and
they said Grimlock so Grimlock will you
come up and join us I think we can
release our Imperial Guards now also we
can the boys can stand down we're good
for a bit thank you okay so first of all
I love to Star Wars on Frank Sinatra's
handprints right there two years ago oh
you what say again oh I loved Star Wars
right there
what do you mean you loved it well are
you in the code we were talking about
when a man you had sex with somebody
there's that what you're saying
can you believe it and it wasn't even a
banana peel I mean I want to know the
story but I don't want you to get in
trouble you know the truth is everybody
here knows this story pretty much I mean
they they sigh don't you an attack there
yeah so they're like Grimlock come out
here and I said and I pulled out the
really weird thing is Jason Mewes is
like can I come and I was like no stay
home you're too dirty he would but he's
never done a sound effect
what so tell us you go back to 99 as
well I go back to 99 but you look young
how old were you 99 12 17 25 you're 25 I
was 25 it's amazing what not being
married and even a lot of pizza and
living your life without children will
do that's the secret kid list right to
the mouth right to the mouth the way I
like it okay so you came out in 99 to
line up with a bunch of strangers you
come solo by yourself I came with a
friend Sam we
the day that the line started it was on
the news yeah and I was like oh my god I
gotta go meet these guys right now well
we didn't go right now we went the
second day and the second day I was
there for about six hours man it was
like Samir said it was like instantly
I'm accepted I found my tribe this is
these are my people and it it was like
crack ever since I can't not be here
this is the greatest Cathedral cinematic
history of all time and we played a game
called who's mouth is on my penis a lot
I had a van at the time I had a van at
the time okay
and do they travel in single file to
hide their numbers not really because I
didn't want to know what's going on but
you know it was a very welcoming van
85 Dodge Ram van this is 99 this is 99
2000 to 2005 2015 16 just to get rid of
the man recently years older but then I
wanted to go to Viking funeral but I
couldn't send it on fire on the ocean
they wouldn't let me so what do you do
when you're not doing this he's a [ __ ]
for our [ __ ] I frequently embarrass my
mother and I work at Trader Joe's do you
wear the truth I thought I recognized
you
so clerks yeah okay I have some ideas
believe me fire away
okay so if your customer and you've ever
said oh it didn't scan it must be free
please kill yourself
okay I don't know if I could build the
whole feature on that I'll be honest
with you I'm telling you I have some
ideas that I can't say on any what you
think something's worse than the sound
effect of I think that could be all
right so so what what would you do this
for other movies are just Star Wars no
it's just Star Wars I'm gonna heed them
although I would do it for Marvel I
can't do it for Marvel yes yeah they've
earned your love and respect oh my god
and my nipples are perky when I talk
about it it's true tell me tell me how
good was the infinity war trailer
infinity war trailer was it was was
really great like it was fantastic I was
leaking out of multiple offices yes I
too was was coming without assistance oh
I didn't know that a male cat lactate
you got me beat there what what now
you're been online for how long eat this
tonight the first night tonight's the
first night have you seen people that
you've seen since 99 is it a homecoming
of sorts you know unattended it's a
homecoming every time and it's seriously
like this is the Thanksgiving that I
wanted you know this is a family that
you can't choose your family that you're
born to but you can you found this
family and I love them all and I can't
believe that we're still and still doing
this after 18 years I mean there's still
magic there yeah
people have yeah people that children
married divorced he'll there's
grandparents here now and I mean we've
gone from you know balding and gray and
off except for me yeah look at you you
you look young and vital and [ __ ] no
kids no wife a lot fun
that's the Trader Joe's life man right
there he's aging like a black dude yeah
hey black don't crack the say something
nice so we can send you off on a great
note I'm just super into it there you
were just saying really cool like real
things well like I said I mean I can't
believe that I still get to do this I
can't believe that this is our life
after so many years and I'm so happy to
to spend this time with you all I I can
I still can't get over it
they're gonna keep apparently they're
gonna keep making these Star Wars movies
whether we want them or not so now that
they're doing like one a year you're
gonna line up every year until yes until
my dick falls off I don't mind off the
Grimlock story give it up for Grimlock
ladies and gentlemen okay
all right so now we got a bit of
backstory and bit of history what not
the pictures becoming clearer it is
becoming clearer okay before these
lovely somebody nice there is today at
the house I I was they delivered a box
of pops pop chips as a move I got a lot
of props tonight the pop chips it was
kind of weird because they they
literally a pop chip van showed up and
my wife was she sits at the window all
the time and she was just like did you
order pop chips and I said no and she
goes well there's a [ __ ] van full of
them outside and the dude brought in
like three cases like this one of them
was phenomenal and I kept them all for
myself they started doing Nutter Nutter
Butter I'm not Nutter Butter but it's
like peanut butter Cheez doodles with
chocolate it tasted like Reese's Pieces
Reese's puffs of cereal it was amazing
but these are
our Wars Galaxies puffs pop chips so I
figured we'd give them out while we're
here Oh Trump style oh yeah no I don't
want to be that guy tell you what if you
want one come up and come up and get it
yeah I don't want that presidential
sheen on me at all
hey man I just to show you like what a
legit are you grabbing two bags there
you go look at that [ __ ] hey pop chips
be very happy the box is yours it says
Star Wars on it
just to show you how legit my Star Wars
fandom is I go back to the first movie I
didn't see it in a theater when it came
out in May I heard a bunch of friends
talk about it and then I begged my
parents can we go see the Star Wars
movie it's got a space dog and we went
to see it and I've described it many
times as I walked in to that theater you
know I was a I was a Catholic I was an
altar boy when I walked out of that
theater I'd switched religions I was a
Jedi from that point forward
so Star Wars was a huge part of my
childhood and adolescence I've tracked
all three movies as milestones
throughout my youth and first love came
from the Star Wars movies I fell in love
with Princess Leia not in the first Star
Wars movie but in Empire Strikes Back
that's that's where she's still March so
everything
Star Wars related in my bedroom shifted
to a kind of more Princess Leia theme
which worried my dad in the 70s but it
was all about like you know she was the
the woman that I kind of I don't know
that I fell in love with I loved her
strong personality and she said she
could put Han Solo and his [ __ ] place
and stuff but she was soft enough to be
like I love you and then he went up
there with I know and then [ __ ] went
down and [ __ ] not that way but you know
went down and the Carbonite pit so I
remember back in the day
like I came out here in 1979 on a family
vacation we took a train trip across the
country and we got here and I bought a
map to the Stars home because I was
trying to find Carrie Fisher's house and
stuff like that is the same trip that I
took pictures right here there was an
address in the maps to the stars home
that you could write to to get like you
know fan mail send fan mail to so I sent
like a letter to Carrie Fisher care of
that address I sent one to 20th Century
Fox like I'm sure many kids did back in
the day but you know god damned if they
weren't up on this [ __ ] back then they
sent back or she well what I thought in
1979 1980s she sent back a signed
photograph that said it's a headshot of
Princess Leia from Empire Strikes Back
and it says best wishes galactically
yours Carrie Fisher now when you look at
it look at that don't that look like a
pen wrote on a piece of paper oh no it
absolutely does hands oh that looks like
my fourth-grade teachers handwriting but
well I was stupid so I bought and I was
just like oh my god like she literally
it was just missing my name but it's
like clearly she had written that
herself Carrie Fisher so you know this
sat next to my bed in a much different
frame there's a more current frame and
every time like I went to bed like there
was a Empire Strikes Back poster I had
on the wall that featured her
prominently it was a drawing it wasn't
one of the classic posters then I would
kiss that I would kiss this and then I
had Empire Strikes Back sheets with
Princess Leia on them and I would do a
lot worse to that than kiss them wash
this but a year after this like you know
I had this for a long time and I was
like you know what man I'm gonna try to
get a different one another one so I
send another fan letter to the same
places and stuff and sure enough I got
another one an exact duplicate
of this one with matching signatures so
it was clearly done on one of those
earliest autograph type machines and so
years later I met and worked with Carrie
Fisher and I showed her this picture she
came over to my house to do a poetry
event once and I brought her I'd bought
this picture out and I was like do you
recognize this and she goes yeah I sign
that and I said you did not that was
done on a machine she's like yeah but I
signed it and then the machine did it
she's going but I remember writing those
words I said get out of here she goes
yeah they asked me like I was just wrote
Carrie Fisher and then they said can't
you do better than that and she's like I
was a writer and I remembered that and
so I wrote galactically oars and she put
it in quotes and I was like you remember
this moment she's gone yeah as she was
like it was a moment where like I had to
decide because it was gonna be on a
hundred thousand pictures and I was like
well I got two of them it was kind of
sweet so my fandom goes way back what
about yours when did you first fall in
love with Star Wars my very first memory
I'm a year younger than you are when
were you born in 71
yeah I'm 70 so my very first memory the
thing that I can actually recall with
vivid detail it's sitting in a theater
when I must have been 6 years old and
seeing the [ __ ] Star Destroyer scream
over my head like that's literally the
first thing that I can remember and it
was also the first time that I
remembered that people wrote this stuff
you know like there were names on a
screen that I hadn't bled think the only
names I've ever seen anywhere we're just
like sports figures or whatever right
written and directed by George Lucas was
oh [ __ ] people make this stuff yes maybe
at some point I could make this stuff
and and it all kind of ties back to Star
Wars and Flash Gordon which is a
knockoff from Star Wars but whatever but
then Star Wars is a knockoff from Flash
Gordon and it's all a [ __ ] twisted
circle but yeah I mean it's it's
foundational for me in a real way the I
remember there was no sense of like now
when you see a movie if it does remotely
well even if it doesn't do remotely well
it's setup for a like not it used to be
set up for trilogies but now whom wants
to build a universe and [ __ ] like that
and have way more than three movies so
this was a movie though that didn't feel
like oh my god there's another one
coming it just felt like they were done
they told the complete story good
defeated evil and that was it so when
they announced hey man there's more of
this or when they start talking about it
enough for it to permeate down to you
know the single-digit age group like I
was seven when Star Wars came out like
suddenly you had something to look
forward to you like white and then I
remember my father gone yeah when I was
a kid they would do these like Flash
Gordon or Buck Rogers serials and they
do them once a week we'd go to the
movies and see them he's gone but they
can't do that with these because these
look better and they cost more money and
stuff but suddenly we had something
beyond Saturday morning television to
look forward to like there's gonna be
another one of these Star Wars movies
and I agree with you completely it was
kind of the birth of the rock star
director because I I knew that guy's
name I was a seven year old who knew the
name of George Lucas who knew the name
of Steven Spielberg because one scared
the [ __ ] out of me and made me never
want to go in the ocean again and the
other took me to space and made me you
know want to live there and find friends
who aren't real but mean more to me than
some blood relatives you know so
learning those names was a big part of
it and you're right it was a sense of
like Oh George Lucas did this he created
Chewie
he created Luke Skywalker in the Death
Star this all came from somebody's
imagination I would agree with that
completely yeah and it's funny like you
look at especially today when everybody
wants at universe everybody wants a
connected series of films that'll tie up
and make everybody billion dollars
moving back to Star Wars one movie one
story just make that first one awesome
make it stand on its own and then in
success you get to spin out all kinds of
Wonder and all kinds of magic but make
the first one great don't worry about
the fifth one when you're making the
first one right it's a time that's kind
of past I was just thinking about it
apropos of nothing but a friend of my
good friend of mine who was it still is
a big movie buff and was my movie friend
back in New Jersey his mom
Dawei one year ago tonight so right
before I came out here he was text to me
and I you know he's like hey you're busy
I said yeah I'm about to go do this and
I sent him a picture of this and he goes
all the Chinese that's awesome he's
going I just texted you because today is
the one year and I remembered that it
was his mom thing so as to do when I get
out there we're gonna be on Hollywood
Boulevard it's 200th episode of fat man
I'm Batman we're gonna give your mom a
shout-out man and so this is for Vinny's
mom give it up for Vinny's mom who's
Bhagawan okay I think that's all the
housekeeping we got I mean we got a
little bit of TCL stuff let's do that
about it okay okay you want to read you
read it I'll read it I put on my best
news but hurt you hurt the bird okay
we're broadcasting today from the
world-famous TCL Chinese Theatre in
Hollywood home of numerous major
motion-picture premieres and historical
and and footprints of cinemas biggest
star I love this place I literally I
mean if this has been the easiest live
podcast I've ever done in my life
because I live two blocks from this
place
so normally I'm always late we were
extra late because I'm so close we could
have walked here so i-i've and I've come
here ever since I moved out here I moved
out here to Los Angeles about 15 years
ago this February it'll be 16 years that
I've been living in Los Angeles living
right up the hill from here one of the
first things I did when I got here to
town was bring my kid here the same way
my father my mother took me here to be
like this is Hollywood and these people
are immortal and that guy is pissing on
the sidewalk so turn around turn around
but the Chinese Theater now the TCL
theater Chinese Theater is still
breathtaking and seeing a movie here
they have another there's a multiplex
kind of over in the Hollywood Highland
complex but seeing a movie here is still
unparalleled a lot of people like
Cinerama Dome a little Center on the
dome but this theater is majestic you go
in and feels like you're in a goddamn
movie theater when when movies ruled the
world that's what it feels like and
everything about it looks Hollywood and
massive and they don't make him like
nobody makes single screens anymore it's
great a place
first time I came to LA I was 19 years
old mm-hmm
by myself I came here I was on an
internship at the Paramount lot and I
was living in temporary housing like
four blocks up this way Oakwood
apartments back in the day and so by
myself I didn't have a car out here I
had a bike I couldn't drink I would just
come here and walk down here and I
remember seeing Unforgiven here I saw
Dracula here there's like the summer of
92 93 I think and this place was a
[ __ ] Cathedral of I'm lonely and I'm
bored and come and show me something
awesome and so I would truck my ass down
here and dodge the urine and the
fingerprints and elmo's and I will come
see movie in what year was the year Zack
and Miri Make a Porno came out we had
our premiere here at the Chinese Theatre
which was like for me the high point of
my cinematic career I'm like oh my god
we're having a premiere at the Chinese
then the movie came out and bombed so I
was like at least I had that premiere at
the Chinese and then I got to come here
earlier this year Stanley got his
footprints he got feet in the hands here
in the courtyard of the Chinese so I got
to emcee the event and watch him put his
hands in and stuff like that it was kind
of magical so this place is if you've
never been in Los Angeles and you do
come you have to visit here it's it is
it's our you know New York has a Statue
of Liberty we got the Chinese Theater
all right we got some newsmen let's get
into the news do we do Star Wars news or
news news news let's do let's go Star
Wars new Star Wars first they Star Wars
as we said Lucasfilm is never going to
stop making Star Wars movies yeah they
better not I mean honestly like see like
I know Disney paid a bunch of money for
the Star Wars library I remember when
they did I was like why would you pay
that much money they're done making
those movies that shows you what a
terrible business person I am
so you know they're gonna make their
money all those billions they spent four
or five wouldn't they spend on stores
for those 4 billion for lucasville yeah
and clearly they're gonna make that back
by the time they before they probably
even get to the third in the trilogy oh
yeah before they get to JJ's movie I bet
you they're back and back in what in the
black or the red where this the black
the black is a good one
blacks a good back in the black
somewhere Native American cries okay so
so they could be making more movies and
remember the guy who directed the
arrival dennee billion didn't even knew
that he did Sicario and Blade Runner and
Blade Runner 2049 wants to make a Star
Wars movie let him yeah he wants to film
the rival is an amazing movie I think he
wants to do one of the stand-alones he
doesn't want to get in the pipeline of a
major episode but he said it's something
I tried using a French accent try all
right let's see something's there to get
in I stopped doing it in a French accent
I won't be intrigued I don't know it's a
Genesis very difficult what is dangerous
with Star Wars right now is to become
its own vocabulary you thought I was
going clues oh you want classy classy
what about giving Boba Fett right the
Boba Fett's standalone it's it's just
work does he get to do a more thinkI
Star Wars movie because it is you know a
rival is a thinking person's movie yeah
I mean I Sicario has a bunch of action
in it yeah and he's good at it yeah he's
a cerebral director so I don't know what
a cerebral Star Wars story is to be
honest is it
hammerhead from the Star Wars bar it's
like you go he start in Star Wars and
the kick classic cantina scene and then
you kind of like see everybody did it
then you push in on him and he's just
like why am i a dick
and it begins this like kind of self
meditation like he looks at himself
reflective movie we learn who this guy
is why did he go to the bar that night
what happened afterwards after he saw
somebody get their arm cut off how does
that affect him and [ __ ] and he's just
like did that guy throw him a quarter a
quarter for a human life what is the
point of existence like it could get
very French did be perfect for Delhi and
any film you
you sold it man you should go talk to
him done John
so yeah well it happened who the [ __ ]
knows there they're still figuring out I
mean Ryan Johnson is gonna add his own
he gets his own trailer did such a great
job with last Jedi they're like take all
the Star Wars what do you want yeah and
he gets to do his own trilogy that's
amazing yeah but for his trilogy segue
he's I set him up for that that was
somewhere professionals this is this is
only our 200th one of these I know right
we're just getting good at it so he has
he's gone on the record by saying he has
no idea what his trilogy is going to be
yet he's really early stages just
figuring it out but he knows that it
won't be Knights of the Old Republic
so he's eliminated that as the option he
must have heard the Internet man I bet
he it's gotta be night so over public
and he wrote [ __ ] no I wonder what he's
gonna do then that seemed like the
logical like go backwards but maybe not
I thought or maybe you do the Clone Wars
I knew we've seen it animated but yeah I
don't know I mean it's it's funny Star
Wars is a is it's an odd franchising
that it's entirely backwards-facing for
the most part like all of the
stand-alones are flashback episodes ro1
Han Solo young Han Solo Wow that dudes
awesome and even the entire the episodes
are about one family a single family
oversee walkers don't let the big bad of
these movies is Luke Skywalker's nephew
that's how kind of small the lens is oh
if the new movies yeah so that's how you
call that's what you think of kylo Ren
you're like that's Luke Skywalker's
nephew
would you break it down like that Star
Wars sounds like Thanksgiving you don't
want to go call him this cool name kylo
Ren which isn't even that cool but still
it's better than Luke Skywalker's nephew
my nephew Ben have you met Ben that's
about one of my favorite part of that
movie man when when they finally said
his name I grabbed my heart I was like
oh my god they named him after [ __ ]
Ben Kenobi and think about what a magic
trick that is right
like she didn't know him Princess Leia
she's like general Kenobi I think you
worked with my dad once you know and Han
Solo met him that day you know for like
a day in space and and he was like your
crazy old man and then one day they
named their kid after so those still
waters run deep on Han Solo alright so
then where does one go where do you
speculate I mean it feels as if it's
still gonna be within the continuity I
don't think he's pushing forward cuz I
think that's four episodes to do but
it's he said it's going to be a
previously unexplored corner of Star
Wars lore so I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
maybe it's like Wookiee planet I don't
know or maybe is she maybe a Yoda
trilogy
Oh Yoda becomes a Jedi Master that's
kind of badass I mean I kind of want the
the fall of Jenna that'd be kind of
Awesome
in rogue one planet that used to be
where they mined the Kyber crystals to
make lightsabers but then the Imperials
took it over and lots of people died and
then you get those two lovely gay couple
who are like we used to be the guardians
of the Wills or whatever that was but
yes the [ __ ] attack on Jenna the fall
of Jenna we've gotta be amazed Oh is the
old Jedi plan it yeah God you know a lot
about rogue one like deep cuts like it
somebody talks to me about rogue one I'm
like all Darth Vader showed up but you
know the names of the planets like I did
when I was a kid and she all right where
are we going next we have a little bit
of DC Comics news okay so we're out of
Star Wars lope will loop back in a Star
Wars
as a hurry everything returns the Star
Wars everything lives back to Star Wars
but uh there's been a you know the
Justice League movie did you guys see
the Justice League movie Justice League
for those at home listening is it's
playing right behind us I think I know
in the Chinese when we walked out I
heard like Diana tell [ __ ] to Bruce
like why this is weird what's yeah so
Bruce it's happening it's happening
behind us behind us it is it is not
happening that much in the box office at
least as much as Warner Brothers would
like okay it uh
to date it's made about 210 million
dollars domestically the Avengers opened
to 215 domestically others is not
overwhelmingly happy what the way things
are going to the point where they're
starting wait wait I got a you kit
you're going too fast and I was not
prepared to do math okay 250 made 210
million in what three weeks of release
for Justice League domestic yeah and and
Avengers opened the weekend three days
to 215 so by even not being good at math
that's not good right it's not great
it's made 500 that was years back like
the Avengers was like six years ago yeah
that's so inflation ticket prices up
so yeah that's nine worldwide on Justice
League is about 560 570 the Avengers got
to 1.5 billion dollars and it's not
looking as if Justice League is gonna
get there
do you think just isn't gonna get to
Wonder Woman like they did 700 and chain
800 and it's not looking that way really
yeah here comes the Warner Brothers
helicopter shut the [ __ ] up everyone
loves it
Justice League forever Avengers never
but yeah so they're starting to shake
some [ __ ] up on the executive side
they've already removed one of the
producers who's overseeing guy named
John Berg who was overseeing all the DC
star people are getting fired over this
people are getting reassigned and
probably
promoted and getting paid more to do
something else cuz I feel like just walk
away don't do it don't step away from
the cow who's this person John burg he
had produced he helped bring them it
lucky has it on his under his belt right
but he's segue to some got a producing
deal but he's not out of the chute
apparently Geoff Johns is going to just
consult on these as opposed to oversee
the entire DC film slate and it seems as
if Zack Snyder is not in line to direct
another superhero movie for Warner
Brothers well he'll have executive
bruisin credits on Aquaman and probably
on flash and you'll have some kind of
credit on Wonder Woman too but it seems
as if his time in the in the saddle is
over I think I think those movies are
gonna age well
maybe not well though age better like
honestly
age yeah they aged me once or twice but
I do I think like there is a vision
there that now is gonna be a lot easier
to see if they ever put out his uncut
version of Justice League because we
talked about on the previous show one of
the previous shows like this material
was cut based on what we'd read online
and we had somebody in the audience who
had actually been there for a test
screening it sounded like there was a
cohesive vision there that at least
really tied Man of Steel and Batman V
Superman together that seems to have
been kind of lost with the reshoots so I
hope they release his uncut version even
if like they have to put in slugs for
like unfinished shot or whatever just to
so he could you could see and tell that
story but then I just read today that
they're releasing a longer cut of
Justice League but with more Joss
material Joss Whedon material is that
what I read did you not read that did
not read that you have news
maybe it's news maybe it's somebody on
the internet speculating maybe it's fake
news but I think they said that there's
I saw cover for a Justice League DVD and
it said that it had over 50 minutes of
cut material or bonus content or
something but
and then somebody said it's the weed and
stuff but this is real specula Tori
right so maybe we shouldn't even throw
that and I know Warner's was not pleased
with Steppenwolf as a bad guy they just
felt that ultimately the audience is not
engaging with giant CG creatures that
they've never heard of before and don't
really ever gonna hear him again yeah
and kind of look like a video game
character and say dumb [ __ ] so maybe
less of that alright Mowgli rinsed it
felt weird well it felt obviously we've
talked about it before like he was just
the predecessor to Darkseid so it felt
like a first act to something bigger
when they announced the Justice League
movie ease back in the day there was two
of them there was a part one and a part
two and so it feels like Steppenwolf was
like you know I'm gonna impress Darkseid
and then at the end of the movie
Darkseid was supposed to show up and
then all of part two would be Darkseid
and then they scrapped that plot
somewhere along the way and just went to
one Justice League movie and started
pretending they'd never talked about a
second Justice League movie and
somewhere along the way somebody forgot
to be like let's switch the villains
like let's take dark side that's more
compelling and stick this character into
Justice League
the only Justice League movie we're
gonna make I didn't have that big a
problem with Steppenwolf because I'm a
New Gods fan and I just like the idea
that like oh my god there he said the
word New Gods like he said the word
Darkseid I'm a real easy mark man like
as long as somebody in the last Jedi
goes well I'm the last Jedi I'm good
like like who they said it like on the
poster so I got a real low bar and stuff
but I guess I guess somebody had to get
in trouble over that yeah so we'll see
what it lead they say that they're gonna
make the big changes start in the
January they still have an aqua movie in
the can they're planning flashpoint
which might be Ben Affleck's last time
as Batman what it really yeah so wait
they're gonna use him as oh if they do
the real flashpoint story then he would
you know Batman kind of
ken's it a little bit but they use Tom
Thomas Wayne through most of the movie I
wonder if he would play his dad or if
they'd get Jeffrey Dean Morgan
they couldn't to play they could which
were making a four-hour movie because he
stretches that dialogue walking - oh
heavens
um but that'd be interesting yeah so
that's their idea is to go do flashpoint
and that'll fix everything
sorta that was Barry Allen's idea look
what happened run Barry run we have run
Barry run indeed what else we got we
have the last bit is is a cute little
heartwarming story okay you know that
Carrie Fisher had a dog right yeah Gary
Fisher Gary Fisher who still he was at
the Kansas City Comicon yeah yeah I met
him and took a picture with him I met
him and I was like I knew your mom and
he was like he apparently has a cameo in
the last year no yeah oh that's I'm
gonna cry that so [ __ ] cool I mean
there there's some pictures that went
online and I'm not gonna say which one
because I'm gonna spoil anything but
there's a scene and one of the
background characters is seen holding
like a small kind of hug like thing
space dog space dog and some like keen
online spotters texted know it detects
it tweeted future Rian Johnson's like is
that Gary there's like [ __ ] yeah it is
good eyes really so yeah so Gary Fisher
is a nice little tribute that's kind of
special man it's kind of lovely that is
actually really sweet yeah she was very
big fan of that dog and that dog was a
very big fan of her apparently so that's
kind of that's kind of magical man
that's the only downside to and it's the
upside as well to watch in this movie is
going like this is it this is the last
time we get to see Carrie as Princess
Leia they said they're not gonna use her
by a footage or anything in the last
movie so this is it and and I like
seeing the billboard with her on it she
just looks beautiful and majestic like
everybody want to think about her and
remember and stuff so it'll be it's a
double-edged swords gonna be wonderful
to see her playing the role but sad
because she don't get to do it again
after
[ __ ] I brought the room down I know it
was a bummer alright so that's the end
of the news that's the end of the news
all right so let's bring the room up the
mark and I have not seen the last Jedi
recently this week I think it was last
night there was an episode of the TV
show speechless on ABC which I
guest-starred on and on the episode they
were having the premiere of the last
Jedi and the kids were gone and I helped
them get into the theater just like if
you've ever seen at one point and I
played myself I'm Kevin Smith
I played myself on Degrassi years ago as
well I'm Kevin Smith so I have the
secondary career where I hang around
children and go I'm Kevin Smith I help
get them out of jams and [ __ ] like that
and get it then I'm Kevin Smith yeah no
vans for me I love Star Wars with my
Grimlock ain't got no [ __ ] band so
you came in that thing braver than I
thought
nice so so in it [ __ ] why did I bring it
up why did I bring up speechless oh
because I was in it and they they had a
fake premiere for the last Jedi so like
they built it on the Fox lot and stuff
and which is weird because you know it's
Fox and not anymore but and these some
Fox executives we're looking out of
their windows like she used to be and so
we have this fake premiere and it was
real cool and stuff and now the real
premiere is coming up yes I can't go I'm
gonna be in Colorado on tour so I'm
gonna miss that are you getting to go or
no I am NOT I'm not that cool anymore
I'm going to a screening on Monday
though so you're seeing it Monday this
Monday Monday coming so you'll see it
before me yeah
now we whisper all that [ __ ] is I here's
what happens I don't give a [ __ ] that
you can spoil it I'm not one of those
people like their badges
I'm not reasonable you can't spoil it
here he hasn't seen it yet but there are
badges that that lining up folks give
out that are color coded and they're
color codings to distinguish what level
of spoiler you allow in your life so
they gave me a green one I thought it
was like is this for stoners and they're
like no it just means that you're cool
with it with spoilers and stuff but
there's a red badge that means laughing
I've never seen a trailer I don't know
who the care I don't even know what Star
Wars is so don't tell me I just like
camping I always wanted to sleep on the
streets
the hobo life's for me got my bindle
stiff and I'm ready to go
okay so the idea that we came up with is
we don't know anything more about the
last Jedi than what we've seen in
trailers so I suggested we both write
what we think is a scene in the last
Jedi based on what we've seen from the
trailers alone so specula torii
fanfiction this is how the [ __ ] Fifty
Shades of Grey got written so you don't
know where this could this could turn us
into publishing magnates but the idea is
a what do they call it fan fiction you
and I have taken a stab at star wars
scenes which they'll never let us do
every yes to our worst movie this is
what ours would be like you want to go
first I think I can go first I texted
you the script I'd you yeah do you have
your phone I do all right
but you printed to that I did like I was
preparing this [ __ ] yeah I know
all right so I think kevlars two
characters in this there's Luke
Skywalker the cab is going to play but I
need a Ray yeah you bet it who wants to
come up here and be and read for Ray
that's just nasty there we go what's
your name
Tatiana I won't give it up for Tatiana
man do you have aspirations to act have
you ever acted before I have acted
before but I shouldn't say that because
that raises the expectations like you've
never done this before I don't even know
how to read so this is keep the bar low
this good all right so you're are you
directing yeah I'm gonna read the screen
directions you're Luke and you're Ray
give me some direction character
direction just be [ __ ] Luke Skywalker
man motivation it's the same advice my
mother gave as a child [ __ ] be Luke
Skywalker you like the last Jedi or does
he feel like I'm the last Jedi I think
he still feels like he's grumpy on an
island somewhere were you asking for me
or for you well I want to know your
motivation for you but that helps my
motivate me tell you something I've been
in the movie business 20 years I never
asked a question that smart that's a
really smart [ __ ] character question
no wonder I'm not good at this all right
here we go take I'm Luke
you're Luke all right exterior weird
space island in the middle of an ocean
day I seen that in the trailer yeah
right Luke Skywalker has been dreading
this moment he's avoided Everett since
ray found him a movie ago as he descends
a flight of stairs from his rock-hewn
airy towards a craggy seaside plateau he
sees it the Millennium Falcon very much
worse for wear looking like a tarnished
relic amongst the rolling blue waters
and windswept grasses Luke walks toward
the lowered gangplank hesitates for just
a second and steps aboard interior
Millennium Falcon he walks down the
dimly lit corridor slowly lightly like
he's afraid to wake someone Luke looks
up at the turret cockpit perhaps we hear
the faintest echo of don't get cocky
he smiles just a little moves on Hawkman
I like your movie
you took it serious his metal hand
gently scrapes across the top of the
hollow chess board that got you and Luke
says to himself let the wookie win you
can just say it let the wookie win hey
[ __ ] don't direct me man well yes
you're right I could have just said it
next time I won't read the screen
direction out loud interior Millennium
Falcon cockpit lip steps into this
chamber and looks around smaller than he
remembers it he reaches over and flicks
a switch the lights and indicators all
hummed to life this ship every time I'm
on the ship I've lost something
as Luke steps in further moving towards
the pilot seats we see Rey standing
behind him in the doorway the first time
I have lost my family my home Luke
flicks the small pair of gold dice
hanging from the ceiling the second time
I lost obi-wan Luke sits in the driver's
seat the camera pays special attention
to his metal hand on the controls the
third time I'd lost well something else
I added that big III improv that bit
like an alum innit Judd Apatow movie and
[ __ ] I'm a new Seth Rogen just like
today I'm just gonna do this is that
cool yes Luke turns the face rain for
the first time behind him through the
cockpit windows we see the turbulent
waters and the last time I'd lost Ben to
the dark side
I know Ren Luke nods almost
imperceptibly what will I lose today he
shakes off his melancholy and smirks
just a little and you found her
jumped on jakku and brought her back
I'm surprised Han let it out of his
sight again if there's anything he loves
more than himself Luke I thought I
thought you'd know maybe the force would
tell you with something on Lucas
realization Dawn's as the answer to the
question he didn't ask presents itself
and the raging ocean waters behind him
stopped frozen in place such power Wow
but before ray can answer I have failed
the father as I have failed the son the
circle is now complete [ __ ] this is sad
man damn it I'm not a good enough actor
to pull this off the waves crash
released from their hold the world is
worse for me being in it everything
everyone I touch dies parents friends
loved ones all dead because of me
you should leave ray take the ship and
go kylo Ren in the first order will
destroy hundreds of planets and kill
billions if everything you touch dies
and there's one more thing left on that
list
help me defeat him and give general
Organa a fighting chance
Luke stands and turns to leave the
[ __ ] kylo Ren we all want that
Luke stands and turns to leave the
cockpit there are two more and if I
cross my sister's doorway again I fear
it will be for the last time Luke exits
leaving Ray alone in the cockpit sister
boom over Wow there it is give it up for
March scene and give it up for Tatiana
man what a performance you want stick
around for the next one we got a ray
performance in this one as well yeah did
you get the script now marks was really
good this is mine and mine is not mine's
kind of it's kind of goofy sounds unlike
you I know
alright let's say can you read this can
we all have to change okay you're
playing ray in my version mark you're
playing Luke okay and I am playing the
supreme leader snoke okay I wrote what I
assume will be the final scene of the
last Jedi but I didn't write it as good
as you wrote yours
here we go I'll be the guy reading the
screen directions and I'll read smoke
you read Luke and you will read right
right here we go
interior supreme and mind you this is
not what happens but it could happen so
if you don't want it spoiled if you've
got a red badge [ __ ] off spoilers
fantasies interiors supreme leader snoke
s-- chamber night old man luke enters
with ray the doors hiss closed behind
them a path illuminates leading to a
seated Snoke and Snoke says I don't know
how does his voice go Gollum II yeah
yeah welcome young Jedi I my sounds more
like the Emperor yeah you went there for
my version Snoke is gonna be played by
the Emperor welcome young Jedi and
welcome old ass Grizzly Adams looking
Jedi Luke and Rey ignite their
lightsabers we've come to bring balance
to the force
nope and make another billion dollars at
the box office but before we do that we
want the truth from you Snoke we want
you to tell us who you really are
don't say Andy Serkis we mean who you
really are in this trilogy Snoke growls
sinister chuckle then he rises from his
throne and descends the stairs
addressing the pair you don't recognize
me Luke Skywalker of course you don't
why would you you never looked back that
day so you never saw what was coming
this day so you're really the Riddler
what are you talking about you motion
captured monster you know what as a
director I got to step in I think your
old man voice is ruining my [ __ ]
script I really do I took your [ __ ]
seriously man and you come on like the
old prospector
[ __ ] this I want more respect for my
material we're going back to the top
damn it
okay back to one if you're like [ __ ]
Affleck just [ __ ] all over my work
alright here we go
[ __ ] take two of this [ __ ] treat it
right I know Mark Hamill I can get the
real guy if I want it too
maybe not this year but you know back in
2001 all right here we go
we'll take it right from that will take
from you don't recognize me you don't
recognize me Luke Skywalker of course
you don't why would you you never looked
back that day and you never so you never
saw what was coming this day so you
really the Riddler what are you talking
about you motion caption monster he
sounds more like Lando but I'll take it
you gotta sound like literally so
alright I'll take that performance I
know like your first one was good your
very first Snoke that sounded like
Gollum yes that was good and then it's
like you both sort of you know why are
you critiquing me all right here we go
what are you doing I'm gonna take it
from your life I have remade myself as
supreme leader snoke but I wasn't always
a Sith Lord we knew each other in
another life old Jedi we fought the
Empire beside one another oh my god are
you handsome
we all thought you're emo [ __ ] of a son
killed you in the first movie
no I'm not Han Solo Han Solo you cared
about me you left behind you crushed my
spirit and the rest of me too
hint hint Ben Kenobi not Ben Kenobi
let's just say I thought I could take on
the whole empire by myself
hint hint on half hint hint
Leia goddamnit sky [ __ ]
you got more midi-chlorians than brains
man I am dak dak from the Empire Strikes
Back or if you saw that scene where I
got smushed The Empire Strikes DAC hard
right in the dick they hit me Derek no
way I checked you I took you before I
have been in the snowspeeder you were
dead
I was napping you could have tried a
little harder to drag me out of there
that's how I got this giant gash on my
head [ __ ] rebels you got that scar on
your head from [ __ ] rebels you know
what [ __ ] this smoke tape Snoke takes
out takes a look out with a lightsaber
and then he says to Rey you're the last
Jedi and credits now if the movie
doesn't end like that I'm gonna be so
disappointed man alright we're done with
you give it up for Tatiana ladies
excellent job
oK we've done the news we've done a
little bit of sketch comedy and now
we're gonna turn to you guys the
audience for QA so we'll take five
questions do we have [ __ ] to give out or
not you gave away all the chips oh my
god that should have been the prize
well I always come prepared anyway so
here we got four really cool Star Wars
cups
that I bought in a store and I haven't
used him yet but I took them out of the
box so one two three four four questions
and that's unless we got other [ __ ] no
we don't mean I can't give away a TV for
a question so not for a question and is
that aspect of it taken care of do you
need us to to sell chances or whatever
to the TV do you guys want to Kevin will
pull we'll have you guys pull a ticket
after we do Q&A after qnet but have they
sold enough or should we be like hey man
here's your last chance to get the TV I
think we're good all right well how LA
casual are you you're like don't beg
we're good it's fine let's start like
kids they have enough so there's a
there's a mic right in the middle so
line up the first four get cups well
only if your questions really good Scout
a really good question it's also got to
go for both me and Mark it can't just be
me you can't just get up there and be
like why did you make that walrus movie
Oh what are these is that right
right so these are challenge coins from
scum and villainy the scum and villainy
Cantina where we normally do the show
right down the street here on Hollywood
Boulevard and JC said their challenge
coins which mean you get what 10% off
10% off your bill for life at the bar
all right so now we got three more ice
seven questions we got seven questions
there we go
and the first question is gonna be you
good sir take us there well
congratulations on 200 episodes guys
thank you so I I got a question my
question is where do you think the rift
is between the DC Universe on television
and the DC Universe for the movies what
do you think because you know they're
killing it with the TV shows and they're
pretty much you know right on the money
and then you have the the movie the
universe that's just taking a complete
left turn what do you think what do you
guys both think is the reason for that
that's a great question come pick a
prize give it up for that question
ladies job
it will generate conversation it will
here's what I think man wow you just
knew which one you wanted man you don't
even look you're like done five here's
what I think I think I'm TV you don't
have as much money to do what you could
do in a movie when you make one of those
movies generally the budgets what a
hundred to two hundred million to tell
one to our story in a very average
episode of flash or Supergirl I've
worked on both so this I know this much
about four million bucks an episode
which you got to do twenty three times a
year so I'm not gonna mass somebody do
the math twenty three times four million
is what so close to a hundred million to
do an entire series an entire season of
television that tells an a story that
spans twenty three hours and it still
doesn't even come close to what they'll
pay to make one of those giant movies
for the studio so in that world you know
since you don't have all the money to
make everything look as beautiful or as
clever or it's look at that what a
mindfuck that is because that's what a
movie is right you watch a trailer and
they show you a scene that you're like I
believe my house and I will go somewhere
that I don't want to be and sit with
people I don't know and overpay for
popcorn because I need to see that on a
big screen that's the magic of films of
movies right TV is the promise of this
is gonna keep going like you got to
watch this and then you're gonna see
another story next week and then you can
see another no story next week and we're
gonna keep you company while you're
going to school or during the work year
or whatever [ __ ] and then we're gonna
[ __ ] off here in the summer and come
back and do it all over again and in
order to make that work it ain't about
spectacle it's not about look at these
amazing things although on those shows
like they'll show you flash running fast
and fighting villains and you'll show
you Supergirl flying and stuff but it's
only about a third of what that show is
those shows are built on three H's heart
heroics and humor heart is the
relationships between the characters you
like these people you genuinely like
that they like each other
and you tune in every week cuz you like
they're like family to me I like their
relationships humor they usually got
some funny stuff going on not like need
you know need slamming gutbuster but
enough humor for you to stick around or
at least take a sense of humor with the
source
material because some of it it tends to
be ridiculous and then heroics sooner or
later you will the boys going to solve
all those problems by [ __ ] running
real fast and that's what some people -
an in for like there's a little taste of
that visual flavor that you'd find in a
movie and they've been expanding that on
those CW shows back when they did
Smallville they didn't have like CG
effects so there's a lot of like fake
metal and air guns and stuff like that
and you were satisfied with that but now
that you've seen you know the Avengers
it's tougher to get you satisfied with
that so they'll spend a little more
money on effects but not nearly as much
as they could spend on a movie so what
they lack in that muscle they make up
for in the muscle of like we gotta love
these characters you got to you got to
fall in love with this world we got to
plot a story that has to stretch 23
episodes versus like a story that has to
stretch only two hours you get to meet
those characters you get to go deep into
their lives you can't go deep in the
life of Bruce Wayne and Justice League
because there's 96 other characters they
got a service as well but if you had 23
hours to tell that story you'd fall in
love with those characters they could go
deeper into them and stuff so I think
that's where the difference is like you
know they got oddly enough less time and
doing those TV shows because they finish
an episode like maybe three days before
it hits air they've got to built like an
assembly system as one episode is
finishing the next stop is starting and
they go hard for like you know months
and until they've got 23 done movie
schedule is much more leisurely and most
of the heavy lifting is done by a bunch
of people behind computers making things
come to life that aren't really there so
I think it has to do more with that like
at the end of it here to put it in these
terms like I'm not a well-hung man so I
had to learn to do other things you know
what I'm saying like because I couldn't
just be like look at this well nobody
should ever but but I had to like learn
to use different muscles instead because
I couldn't play the game you know like
others could or whatever so what you
lack you know you make up for in other
areas and on those shows they make up
for it with rich character development
will you'll follow those characters for
like ten years
like in some cases what do you think
it's a lot of what he said but it's also
the idea that that you cannot throw
money at the problems you have on
television you cannot fix it by saying I
will just will do any post well throw
more effects on it will whatever it's
the problems need to be solved on the
page and TV is about characters you
invite you're inviting characters into
your lives it's far more intimate than
movies are you're going out you're
leaving the comfort of your home to go
to the movies you're inviting characters
into your house you're watching them
from your bedroom and so you're forming
a bond with those characters the way
you're not actually with movie
characters and you cannot solve those
problems by throwing money at them there
has to be on the page they have to be
smart and that's the way you get
creative problem solving and that's what
you fall in love with it with somebody
you're gonna tune into for four or five
six years over and over again there's
the secret man so obviously we know what
to do they should just hire us no but
clearly that's where like TV has it all
over movies they got time to like burrow
into your heart and soul moviemakers got
to get it done in two hours or less and
make it impact and steal your heart and
then get you in your car you know on
time to go back to your life but you're
right man it's the intimacy of inviting
people into it inviting people on TV
into the home as you sit there and watch
it this is gonna sound very
name-dropping but we're in Hollywood so
it stands to reason years ago there was
a movie called Good Will Hunting that I
was an executive producer on so I got to
meet Robin Williams and we were outside
a bar in Toronto where they were
shooting and so as we were heading into
the bar there people across the street
like lined up watching and [ __ ] and
people were yelling out more more and
they were talking about Mork from ork
like a character he [ __ ] played on
Mork and Mindy in the 70s and when we
were making Good Will Hunting it was
what 97 or something like that so you're
talking about a show that is almost you
know at least 15 maybe 20 years old I'm
my math may be off so I said man like
wow that's crazy like you know he's done
a bunch of things like I would imagine
people would be like good morning
Vietnam or something like that anything
closer than [ __ ] Mork and he goes no
man it'll always be more because Mork
was in their house
he's like I've been in a bunch of movies
but like Mork came to them every week
he's like from now until dad I will be
more to a lot of people and it's true
it's like you're inviting cats into your
home and they're a big part of your life
think about how much you build your week
around that schedule like their shows i
watch with my wife where i'm like we're
putting everything aside and this is our
[ __ ] time man because that's our
program as if we made it and we didn't
because if I made it it'd be off the air
so all right we're good with that we're
good with that jump to the next question
how are you sir hey I'm doing great
I want to thank you guys for all the
funny and all the geekdom and my first
question and I have two things what do
you guys thoughts about Marvel and Fox
come together what's coming next and I
actually made some posters Star Wars
included for both you guys yeah oh my
god give it up for the poster man and
take a prize because we'll definitely
answer that question do you want to take
it out and show folks or no okay feel
like you do it all right I will
I [ __ ] made the posters you can even
open if I did my part leaves you can do
shut unroll this while we're starting
yeah I mean while I whip this out okay
the you know last month they wimzie door
a couple weeks ago they wimzie de bout
you know Disney buying a bunch of Fox IP
this week and we talked about it on the
show on Tuesday it looks like it's going
for oh that's beautiful
does it hold it up so folks could see
that's one and then there's another
under it I think they've since announced
that it's going forward as beautiful as
a pulp fiction a living one that's
awesome
do another
do them all
what is that all of this for get out
very nice where can they find your
artwork yeah he's a talented
[ __ ] just yell it out work in
the air my name is Brandon gash you
could find me on Instagram Brandon dot
gash really nice stuff give it all those
posters I designed and drew you did yeah
I will hire you sir give up a band oh
that's awesome oh my god it's a mug
white okay they've since announced that
it's happening that Disney is you know
the final announcement has it happened
but for 60 billion bucks boo that's nice
for 60 billion bucks they're buying a
bunch of Fox properties a and and that
includes of course what everyone's most
excited about is the x-men Fantastic
Four are gonna be rejoined with the
other Marvel characters in the Marvel
family I hear you and then that also
means that the Simpsons oh that's
awesome
probe it also means the Simpsons the
x-files Planet of the Apes a bunch of
stuff is going to be owned by Disney now
I think we talked about on the show the
other night I Vegas as a fan I'm happy
as [ __ ] like yeah they're gonna bring
all the Marvel Universe together deep
cuts down the road I know but you know
I'm 47 now by the time I'm 70 Disney has
enough IP to just cross everything over
so [ __ ] Luke Skywalker is gonna meet
you know magneto
and you know in fan owes his backyard
like they'll be able to end Mickey Mouse
will be there as well so they'll be able
to do a mega mega crossover with all the
IP they on but Mark pointed out go ahead
take the other side I mean the way the
motion picture industry works the way
creative business works is if I have a
script that I want to sell I now have
six buyers to go to six giant movie
studios all could pay for it if one of
them goes away it affects in a really
big way the economics of Hollywood
there's one less bio there's one less
people giving folks jobs and if somebody
points out other lines hadn't even
thought of if if Disney buys Fox it is
not just that they tape over the signs
on the Fox
now say Disney a bunch of people gonna
get fired because Disney is not a
redundant company it's like we have
distribution we don't need Fox's
distribution we have dudes you drive
trucks we don't need your guys who drive
trucks we have we're Disney we have all
the animation we need oh that's right so
as we might not need your animation
company's Simpsons whoever you've been
using for 30 years like they will look
for places to cut and make it more
efficient and they don't want double
redundancies so there's gonna be a lot
of people who will eventually lose their
jobs if this happens but yeah we get
x-men avengers that's awesome but for
way to ruin it for everybody man you
like yes we will get a crossover but a
lot of people are gonna lose their jobs
behind this I mean everything comes with
a price it's true um so is a good thing
and a bad thing like many things in life
like a positive and a negative
somebody's gonna win somebody's gonna
lose which kind of sucks that somebody
has to lose cuz it sounded like we were
all gonna win I know why I know like oh
my god we all want this so bad but there
are a bunch of people at Fox who were
like oh yeah the mulder and scully where
they find Dark Phoenix episode I'm
telling you man think of the crossovers
they could do it's astounding
alright let's do another one did he go
are you my friend hello how are you good
how are you I'm so great me too so
[ __ ] good Oh God okay hi
I've been trying I've been like reacting
this to myself over and over but I guess
that that's why I can put it a lot of
people see Harrison Ford as Han Solo and
with regards to the solo solo movie
young solo young solo um I know that I
would like it to be basically just like
a longer Star Wars version of the
opening to the Last Crusade oh what a
great idea that belongs in a museum
exactly and then like he gets the scar
in his chin and [ __ ] like that yeah
anyway I was just thinking about that
let's put a pin in that real quick that
was the original fanservice scene like
that that opening to Last Crusade with
them gone come on let's give him
everything they want we're gonna see how
it gets the scar we're gonna see why he
don't like snakes we'll see where he
gets the [ __ ] hat oh they'll [ __ ]
love it they'll slap their fins together
like a seals they all
and they did I remember seeing that in
the theater as a kid and be like it's
happening like you know that was and
that was the earliest memory I think of
a movie where they're like let's do it
let's give the fans every little piece
there they want we've built up enough
back story where we can do this and then
it would have actually led to you know
nuke in the fridge but we won't go back
I was just wondering what your feelings
were about that maybe if you had any
predictions and how you felt about Ron
Howard taking over the movie halfway
through production I wonder I mean you
know we heard of course that the
geniuses behind the lego movie and what
was the other mode juncture and the 21
Jump Street franchise Lord and Miller
yeah I I thought they were great choices
for the movie and then they got
shit-canned and then they said Ron
Howard is gonna come finish the movie
and then they shot for a longer than it
felt like Alicia Lee there like I was
two weeks left and then it felt like
they shot for much longer than that and
the indication may you know I never
worked on a big expensive movie but I
know people that have the indication
they're the implication there is that
maybe they've shot more than you know
the last two weeks maybe there are some
changes made and we've read stories or
heard stories about who jump to help
Omar coming yeah yeah yeah Michael
Williams Michael Wong Kate Williams like
okay Williams was in the movie
originally and now he's not in the movie
he couldn't come back for the reshoot so
they just took his character out and and
then they added a few actors that
weren't in there in the first run so it
seems like maybe they're doing a lot
more work than initially indicated which
is not you know the scariest thing in
the world because that's what we heard
right before it rolled one eye they were
in real production was wrote one they
were like they shut down they're going
back now there's another directory blah
blah blah and that turned into a
wonderful flick like a really enjoyable
Star Wars movie so maybe we'll get some
of that here as well I mean Ron Howard
no slouch in the director's chair by any
stretch of the imagination and the dude
made Willow and if you watch willow it's
pretty much a Star Wars movie so I think
it's in good hands it's kind of shitty
they took
those two guys I would have liked to
have seen a Star Wars movie that a real
sense of humor about itself these movies
always have sense of humor to him but
one that was kind of in a little meta or
whatever they were planning on doing but
I guess we're never gonna see that
version but you know Ron's at Ron
Howard's version I'm sure will be
completely fun and watching it's gonna
be like the new buried in the Lost Ark
is who's got the Miller and Lord cut and
how can I [ __ ] watch it you'll never
get that cut man you dad they'd have to
sneak that [ __ ] out in a droid they'll
never let us see that all right you good
come and get a prize you get prize man
give it up for a great question later
and then we go to you what's going on
are you guys Pro pork or anti pork and
how do you think porks will taste that
deserves a prize come up and get full
pork or anti pork I'm I am Pro pork I
they look adorable
I think it's a good you know clearly
somebody's trying to sell it to e but I
don't care they look cute as long as
they function you know well in the story
in my head they all assemble into a
monster pork I'm sure that's not what's
gonna happen and [ __ ] but I know there
is an anti pork contingency out there I
live in a house with an 18 year old kid
who loves animals so when she saw the
pork she was like poor they look like
bunnies and she has a bunny so it's very
Pro pork in the house what about you I
am I am cautiously Pro pork
you know like I'm hoping that they don't
veer into Ewok territory [ __ ] he walks
just don't let him be charged over for
heaven sakes I mean I'll take a walks
I'm I'm gonna say they taste of baby
seal oh my god you lost the audience for
us I mean if you've never had a baby
seal it tastes like chicken so if I had
to guess what they taste like they taste
like when you eat them they don't die
they live forever
had to save us from your [ __ ] baby
seal comment that's a dude who has to go
home alright here we go over to you my
friend hi doing hey okay so thinking
back on your life what was the moment
that you can remember you probably knew
a little bit too much about Star Wars I
know exactly what it was for me and it
changed my life
to a large degree I was at film school
in Canada I went to the Vancouver Film
School and I met this guy Scott Mosier
wound up you know producing a lot of
movies I do a podcast with him called
SModcast Scott and I had similar
sensibility when smear was talking about
finding his tribe it's definitely a
moment when I found my tribe when I sat
down and talked to that guy we had a
similar sense of humor and and and Star
Wars like this is at a time now you jump
on the internet and just enter Star Wars
and anyone's willing to tell you what
they think about it good and bad this
was at a time where they were just some
old movies that you know there was no
talk of making more of them and stuff
that was that every once in a while
they'd make an Ewok TV movie and that
was that so I remember I watched you
know I had a lot of free time living in
Vancouver because you only had school a
certain amount of time during the day
and I brought my entire laserdisc
collection with me and so I had the
trilogy so one night I watched the
trilogy back-to-back and then the next
day him and I were at school and we went
to this little coffee shop he drank
coffee and stuff I didn't so I watched
him drink coffee and we sat there
talking and so I said you know and I
watched last night I watched all the
Star Wars movies and he goes oh I love
those movies so was your favorite and
essentially the conversation that's in
clerks started there where Dante I'm
Randall of talking about Empire and Jedi
started in that conversation in the
coffee shop so him and I were sitting
there talking about stars but breaking
it down like my theory was like I was
watched all three movies and I'm pretty
sure I got it down to a science now I
think the Empire is a theocracy it's a
religion of a government based on faith
based on a religion and the Empire or
the Emperor is kind of like the Pope I
don't know what Darth Vader
but like it's weird when you're looking
at through that prism so Scott and I
started talking about the religion Star
Wars and I started talking about
terrorists and people who have strange
beliefs like hence the destruction of
the Death Star
so the Death Star conversation from that
movie kind of started in that space and
there was a guy who was sitting at a
table away from us who I could see out
of the corner of my eye and as we talked
about Star Wars like the dude stopped
reading his paper and then started
leaning forward and listening to what we
were saying and I saw him eavesdropping
and the more I saw him eavesdropped the
more ridiculous we would take the
conversation and I saw his expression at
one point be like they don't understand
Star Wars at all you know so I remember
I was like wow that made an impact so
when I wrote clerks like a year later I
started writing that Star Wars stuff
into it particularly for that for that
feeling of like oh [ __ ] like somewhere
out there somebody's gonna be like yeah
man that's how I used to think about
those movies so that was the moment
where I realized I know way too much
about Star Wars when I described it as a
theocracy I was like you're overthinking
this [ __ ] but thankfully the world moved
in that direction
like you know in ninety this was we're
talking ninety-two you know there were a
bunch of people that were like as smear
said like you didn't talk about Star
Wars is just everybody it wasn't even
didn't assume people still cared about
those movies and stuff so it completely
shifted for me when I saw a stranger
eavesdropping on our conversation I was
like oh people still care about this
[ __ ] and so I wrote that into the script
and Star Wars like that is the scene
that most people remember from that
movie the most that was my bridge to the
world that got me out of New Jersey
nothing I was trying to get out but it
took me around the world and like the
first time I've told the story many
times I went to France for the Cannes
Film Festival with that movie they told
me after the screening they're like
you're gonna sit down with a French
journalist from cashiers do cinema which
is a very you know [ __ ] hoity-toity
film magazine over in France and I was
like I don't speak French so like he
doesn't speak English either so it's
good
and I was like well what are we gonna
talk about like what would he be
interested in this movie that was shot
in New Jersey and stuff there like he
desperately wants to talk to you so I
met him in the cafe and he looked French
as [ __ ] had a beret little mustache he
was smoking a cigarette like this almost
like a joint and so I sat down I was
like Bonjour and the dude looked at me
and he goes Jay and Silent Bob they are
not like r2d2 and c3po no and I was like
oh my god he's a brother from another
mother
my International Star Wars buddy and we
sat there talking about Star Wars that
was what he liked most about clerks he
was like you talked about Star Wars and
I was like yeah man cuz nobody was
really talking about the Internet if we
waited 10 minutes the internet was
coming we'd all talk about Star Wars
again but this was at a time where like
he too was frustrated at the lack of
Star Wars conversation and even though
we didn't speak the same language we
just sat there relating via Star Wars
like I was just like at one point it
came down to music he was like ah Star
Wars I said yeah Star Wars right dun dun
dun dun and dinner and he went on dun
dun dun dun did I'm we were like dad dad
dad bridge cultures man and because of
that movie that's when I realized that
and I know a lot about Star Wars
it's my it's my like icebreaker and now
internationally I just go up to foreign
people they like Star Wars doesn't work
the same as it did back then but that
was fun you first my French accents
better than your friends you're right
you're you're absolutely right uh I
think for me I was working at
Entertainment Weekly at the time in the
in the late 90s and and the first
trailer for Phantom Menace broke which
great thriller whatever the movie and
there being the trailers [ __ ] amazing
as fantastic and like we all just
stopped working for two hours when we
waited for download on our ancient
Macintoshes the
but I was sitting at this meeting and
you know everybody's talking about
whatever tool or whatever and somebody
was like you know we're talking about
how we're gonna cover the movie
somebody's like well it's about Hannah
Canseco got a fucked-up name is Anakin
like well it's actually named after
Kenneth Anakin a British documentarian
that George Lucas was very fond of and
the room stopped and everybody's like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I know
too much about Star Wars yes you're
editing all of the Star Wars stuff I
gotta be honest with you I didn't even
know that well done man that's deep cuts
and [ __ ] that was the nerd testing you
failed come up and get a prize my friend
give the first question that was a great
question on to you my friend how are you
hi you guys so good we got some two cups
left awesome all right my question you
guys you guys are both great writers and
great director and always the one though
you guys like yes you guys are great
writers and you guys love TV so always
wonder if you guys could travel back in
the past Aintree
direct or write on a TV show which one
would it be oh my god what a great
question come get the cup that's
fantastic so not to reboot something
that already existed no just go back in
time and direct an episode of your
favorite show or something oh really
like that's it just pick a show that I
could have written an episode of or that
you would have liked to have written
episode that's [ __ ] tough man across
my entire life TV raised me so I'm
trying to think honestly for my from for
me I might go back and do an episode of
moonlighting just to work with Bruce
Willis before but also I just love the
writing on that shows incredible like
you know if you could pull I I only wish
I could be as good as some of those
scripts were write as well as some of
those scripts read [ __ ] I can't even
speak so obviously I can't write an
episode of moonlighting but that would
be it man I love the interplay between
the characters I would do an episode
before they had sex when there's the
sexual tension was still high that's
kind of
one of the lovely aspects of the show if
you've never seen moonlighting it's kind
of like castle same format kinda isn't
it ya know very much so to some degree
what would you do
part of me wants to say Dukes of Hazzard
Wyatt just so that I could go and say
y'all realize this is really [ __ ]
racist and then just leave this is
[ __ ] bring on bringing Cleavon little
but III think it would be it's a toss-up
between angel and Battlestar Battlestar
Galactica see I couldn't pick that I
could never write that good that show
was [ __ ] brilliant it's brilliant if
I could have been in one writers room
ever I think it would have been
Battlestar just to [ __ ] learn just to
watch out and see how they did that just
did just to write dick jokes for people
and that was how many episodes they do a
season they did ten the first season
miniseries then 10 then 13 and then yeah
so it was less than 13 every season hmm
yeah that was a fantastic show but I
don't think I don't think I would lean
to it as much as I loved that run I just
don't think I could even touch it like
there was some bad episodes of
moonlighting where I'm like I think I
could do that but there was never a bad
episode of Battlestar yeah I mean an
angel especially once it sort of hit its
stride but like third fourth season when
they knew what the show was and sort of
Unchained a little bit from the rest of
the Buffyverse in a way and just became
really [ __ ] fun I mean there's an
episode Williams who gets turned into a
puppet and he's a wee puppet man and so
just to be in that room with those mad
geniuses going to work would be a little
arias very cool all right here we go
last magical inch and you get a cup
there's a cup okay so I'm gonna leave on
a Batman question if you could make the
next villain in a Batman movie be any of
the obscure villains from the 50 and 60s
which one would it be
like I vote King Tut all the way like
King Tut alright so we can call from the
TV show as well who would I pull let me
see I would go with I'm gonna go with
you know what he's not a villain but I
think he could make an interesting story
I'd go with bat-mite that way you kind
of get to [ __ ] with the the eighth
dimension a little bit and you get to
like unmake his world and kind of put
him in weird situations it would be like
an acid trip version of Batman Grand
Morrison did it really well with his run
so I go with Emily I'm hoping the
character is what I think the
character's name is was an egghead was
that Vincent Price surprise from the
show again I think I think there's a
there's real pathos to egghead I mean
what's it like growing up with that
[ __ ] head like it's the tragedy they
get I think is is it's operatic almost
and it's debts so yeah I'm gonna get
there it is you want a cup come get a
cup give it up for alleged gentleman
through the TV ahead what is this it's a
Justice League Kinkos for popcorn like a
collectible popcorn tin I mean like I
would like this Tin Man and I would like
some popcorn that's kind of sweet it's
like a little garbage can it's like they
knew I'm kidding man I like the movie I
paid to see it twice all right here we
go man we are raffling off or we're not
but the good folks here from lining up
all right and the TCL Chinese Theatre
TCL particularly are raffling this TV
off credit where credit's to and also a
big round of applause for the TCL for
letting us do this here tonight has been
so fun it's a dream I didn't know I had
coming true into crazy like honestly we
only found out like last week JC was
like would you guys ever want to do this
at the Chinese and we were like what do
you mean JC was like we could do a show
in the courtyard and I was like that
I've never imagined I would ever do that
that's the closest I'll get to get my
feet in here and [ __ ] like that
so yeah let's do it and when you heard
were you like yeah
there's no there's no framing what the
[ __ ] this is
yeah but it's awesome there's a picture
that they sent us before we got here of
like all the seats lined up in front of
this place and it just looked fantastic
and then we saw the tiny banner up front
it was really [ __ ] special for our
200th episode this is the way to do it
so thank you guys all so much for coming
ok I'm shaking it up but I'm making you
pick a [ __ ] that's right here we go
raffle on the TV I've got three of these
TVs at home myself ladies gentlemen we
use them on fat man time we did in their
wonderful TVs
may the great god of oddball guy John
alright okay seven one seven I'm
assuming everybody's a seven was it nine
six 963 did you win the TV come on up
here man what's your name Veronica give
it up for Veronica she won the TV how
awesome but you can't watch it until
you're out of line when you're all done
with one a new TV
it's a Christmas miracle give it up for
our ladies gentlemen look at this bad
boy
4k HD 55 inches how sweet man your car
is big enough I know do you how you get
it home all right you put it my house if
you want
don't mind if I unbox it just walking up
the hill that's great man Congrats
that's fantastic give it up for a ladies
gentlemen give it up for the good folks
the TCL providing us a TV how'd you feel
about show 200 my friend man I think
it's it is one for the books this we
could not have done a better 200 show I
got I get a lot of you know because I've
always just in hockey jerseys I get a
lot of hockey jerseys no matter where I
go but this is actually one that I
cherish and will actually wear it's a
it's a TCL Chinese Theatre Jersey man
that's awesome that is kind of dope I
thank you guys for giving me that and I
thank everybody for showing up here
tonight and I thank the folks at home
who have been following along with this
show for 200 episodes this proves that
you don't need talent to have to have
you thanks man to have your own show
like think about like in our day jobs
we're always trying to prove our
abilities as writers but this allows us
to just love on [ __ ] and and discuss
[ __ ] like a fan does without worrying
about careers probably why we don't get
hired for anything I I think that's
probably true at least on my case for
more than one thing but I'll trade it
man cuz it's worth it I love doing the
show thank you for doing it with me
thank you for inviting me into the fat
gave me frame and thank you all for
coming tonight and for listening at home
that's all for this week for fat man I'm
Batman I've been Kevin Smith and I've
been working hard tune in next time same
bat time same bat Channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith good I
Dollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
you